founders trusted the Senate to rise
above short-term passions at the last
moment Senate Majority Leader Mitch
McConnell altered his proposed rules for
the impeachment trial gone was the
possibility that the evidence connected
during the various House inquiries might
not be entered into evidence in the
Senate trial and the Democratic party
house managers and White House lawyers
would now have three days and not two to
make their opening statements that left
the issue of witnesses and documents
House Democrats argue that they were
withheld in the course of their
inquiries into whether Donald Trump was
withholding congressionally mandated
military aid for Ukraine in return for
an investigation into former Vice
President Joe Biden and that these must
be produced in the Senate trial so
leader McConnell wants a trial with no
existing evidence and no new evidence a
trial without evidence is not a trial
it's a cover-up
the White House argues that the request
for more evidence proves the Democrats
don't have a strong case against the
president they said in their brief we
have overwhelming evidence and they're
afraid to make their case think about it
think about it it's common sense
overwhelming evidence to impeach the
President of the United States and then
they come here on the first day and they
say you know what we need some more
evidence the White House also argues
that the documents and witnesses are
privileged in order to shape foreign
policy the President must be able to
have private deliberations with advisors
and that's an argument rejected by the
Democrats make the argument that the
president's conduct here was was it was
conduct that every president should be
allowed to engage in and I think that
most Americans don't believe that that
mr. Chief Justice I yield back the
Democrats failed to pass their
amendments under McConnell's rules
though there will be another chance to
debate the need for more witnesses and
documents but only after opening
arguments and the cross-examination of
the house managers and White House
lawyers he just watch Donald Trump was
reported to be monitoring proceedings
while attending the World Economic Forum
in Switzerland his position remains
unchanged
well let's cross over tisha a proton
sees following events for us from
Capitol Hill so where are we right now
in terms of that Senate process via the
amendments keep coming we're now on the
fifth amendment that's been proposed by
the Democrats this time to subpoena
documents from the Pentagon the
Department of Defense relating to that
Ukrainian military aid the Democrats
allege was held up as part of a quid pro
quo in order to get an investigation
into into Joe Biden said it should have
definitely apparent getting getting
restless we understand Mitch McConnell
seems to be in what I suppose passes as
high drama and the currents in the
currents of secession and McConnell got
up and said look after the last word
after the last amendment failed can we
just stack all these amendments together
because they're all so similar and Chuck
Schumer got up and said no and I only
pointed out that he had a good many in
his word amendments still to go but he
said no because he feels that each one
individually is very important to get on
the record what the Democrat says look
we will have a vote eventually under
Mitch McConnell's rules which will be
passed eventually at some point in the
coming hours as to how the trial will
progress but that might just be a
blanket vote on whether to admit more
documents and witnesses if it doesn't
pass that no one will ever know what the
documents of witnesses were that weren't
admit it so what the Democrats are
trying to do to get on the record and to
try and get into the ether of American
public opinion and say these are all the
things we have to have to have a fair
trial in in the Senate but as we heard
the Republicans say look we will have a
vote on documents or witnesses at a
later stage and anyway why do you need
more evidence when you said you had the
evidence already to impeach the
president or shall leave it there and
follow events through the night thanks
sir she AB well Michael Isikoff
is chief investigative correspondent for
Yahoo News he says while the Democrats
have been unable to get any major
amendments across the line the first day
of the trial hasn't been a total failure
for them well certainly the votes the
voting has been pretty much as well it's
been exactly as expected Mitch McConnell
had the votes and he's prevailed on all
these amendments but I gotta say I think
today was also a good day for
House Democrats I thought Adam Schiff
did a pretty bang-up job just laying out
the house case in a very effective way
and emphasizing the stonewalling as it
were that the White House has been
engaged in in for refusing to turn over
documents and allow witnesses to testify
the question there are two audiences
there the there's the Senate audience
and we just don't know how
whether he's getting any traction with
Senate Republicans to get those votes he
needs those four votes that he needs if
I thought it was noteworthy that Susan
Collins did put out a statement after
ships opening presentation saying she
was likely to vote for witnesses that I
think although she used the word likely
pretty much locks are in so that's one
solid vote there for opening this up to
witnesses they need three more Lisa
Murkowski and Romney are assumed to be
in that camp as well so it's like one
more will they get but I was saying
Schiff had two audiences the broader
audience was the American public